les secouristes sont à pied d'oeuvre à
carquive selon les autorités au moins
quatre personnes ont été blessées
lorsqu’un missile russe est tombé près
d'une tour d'habitation Yulia cartienne
vivait dans ce bâtiment
elle raconte à boire entendu deux
explosions un son horrible un second
missile à atteint un bâtiment
universitaire faisant au moins un blessé
au même moment des combats acharnés ont
lieu dans les quartiers nord de
backmouth l'un des points les plus
chauds du front à l'est du pays l'armée
russe aidé par les mercenaires du groupe
Wagner tentent de s'emparer de la ville
presque entièrement détruite le
président volo du meilleur de Lenski a
reconnu que la situation si complique
pour ses troupes
tout comme sa voisine Solidar tienne le
coup face à l'envahisseur russe
des fidèles ont prié pour la paix dans
le sous-sol d'une église de la ville
dernière un obus a volé dans son jardin
et qu'une balle est entrée dans sa
maison les autorités ukrainiennes
s'attendent à une possible offensive de
Moscou plus tard ce mois-ci
le ministre de la Défense dit prête à y
faire face même si toutes les armes
occidentales n'auront pas le temps de se
rendre jusqu'à lui parmi celles-ci
jusqu'à 140 chars occidentaux un premier
char léopard 2 du Canada a d'ailleurs
quitté Halifax samedi
Alex nicov critique cependant la
réticence des Occidentaux a envoyé des
avions de combat en Ukraine une
hésitation qui croit-il pour écouter
encore plus de vie à son peuple des
déclarations faites lors d'une
conférence de presse qui sera
vraisemblablement sa dernière qui est va
annoncer en soirée son remplacement à la
suite de de corruption au sein de son
ministère pour sa part la Russie fait
face à plus de sanctions l'Union
européenne a mis en place aujourd'hui un
embargo sur ses produits pétroliers
raffinés et le Canada sanctionne
désormais une cinquantaine de
propagandistes russes dont le chanteur
et animateur de télévision Nicolas et
victorowicz mascov ici Élise Allard
Radio-Canada Montréal